I'm a preacher who teaches as opposed to
a teacher who preaches I am everything
that I am is defined by my Christian
belief and my Christian experience and
everything I do stems from that whether
it's preaching or teaching or counseling
or whatever else goes with the territory
people have asked me well what are you
how would you define yourself what is
your your ultimate label and my ultimate
label is a believing Christian that's
what I am my mind is not on hold my mind
is an interesting place reasonably well
furnished and it ranges up and down a
host of avenues but I continue to hold
fast and the faith in which I was
brought up and I'd like to present it as
an interesting challenge to people who
are smarter than I am that's the fun of
being the hardwood preacher I preached
people who are infinitely smaller than I
am I know more than they do but they are
smarter than I am and that is great fun
trying to take them as far as you can
before they overtake you
I think I'm a very literate preacher I
like language I love words and i like to
make words dance and do things and i
like to cause people to think about all
these words are contributing to these
ideas and forwards to dance in their own
heads so in that sense I it's an odd
description but I think I'm Oh a wordy
preacher words are very important to me
the right word at the right time fitly
spoken in my view was the most powerful
engine on earth so I take very great
care with the words and the language i
use and how i put words together and I
think it's no accident but one of the
great greek words logos means word and
Jesus is often described as the word the
word in Connie I'm an incarnation or
preacher I tried to bring words ideas
and concepts to life and that's for me
the glory of language the glory of
rhetoric that's what I do